all I want to get
is a little bit
[Music]
closer all I want to know
is can you come a little
closer here comes the breath before
before we get a little bit
closer Here Comes The Rush before we
touch Come a Little
Closer the doors are on open the wind is
really blowing the night sky is changing
overhead it's not just stop physical I'm
a top won get all so critical so let's
make things physical I will treat you
like you're so
typical I will treat you like you're
soical all you think lady
is getting underneath
me all I dream
L is how to get you underneath
me here comes the heat before we meet a
little bit
closer here comes the spark before the
dark Come a Little
Closer the lights are off and the Sun is
finally setting my sky is changing
overhead it's not just a physical I'm
the top get all so critical so let's
make things physical I will treat you
like you're a
soal I want you close I want you I want
treat get typical I want you CU I want
you I want treat
[Music]
here come the dreams of you me here come
the
dreams here come the dreams of you me
here com
dreams it's not just St physical I'm the
top get up so critical so let's make
things physical I will treat you like
your so
typical I want you CU I want you I want
the treat
get I want you CU I want you I want the
I
treat
I all I want to get
is a little bit
closer all I want to know
is can you come a little closer
[Music]
what up there friends I hope you enjoyed
that little flow session uh real quickly
I just want to put out a huge thank you
to flow toys for sponsoring this video
and giving me an excuse to go out and
find beautiful places to flow in if
you'd like to grab a set of those
beautiful LED that I was using in this
video you can do so by using the promo
code Drex Factor April that is
a 2024 at checkout over at flowtoys.com
yes it is different from the pattern and
it's because uh somebody shared my
original code for the month on a bargain
site so here we are again that is
drexfactor APR 2024 to get 10% off your
uh prop of choice at checkout
flowtoys.com thanks again to the
wonderful Folks at flow toys for
supporting me in this wonderful way
speaking of folks I'd love to thank for
supporting me uh need to thank the
friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyate ter light
toys spinballs and Ultra PO for helping
to make the videos on this channel
possible you can learn more about all
these amazing companies and the work
that they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this here video and
special thanks to the non- buus friend
of the channel Becca Becken thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission uh finally this
video would not be possible were not for
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much for
your supporting my channel my work and
my mission and if you out there watching
like what you see and want to support
these videos as well you can do that by
heading on over to patreon and signing
up at patreon / drexfactor poo there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out and finally if you'd like to
check out more of my flow videos I will
include a link to a playlist of those
down in the description as well as up
here on screen thank you so much for
watching make sure to get on Flow today
uh and I will see you with a new video
very very soon take care now peace